all across the country a lot of
frustration for travelers this holiday
weekend but so far no major problems
here in southern nevada we'll take that
we have team coverage this evening first
we begin with madison kimbrough and
madison is at the airport
some positivity in the air this fourth
of july weekend as travelers make their
way to baggage claim terminal three and
although national flight delays are
causing real frustration here at harry
reid international it's been nothing but
a smooth landing so far according to
flightaware as of now there are more
than six thousand flights that have been
cancelled nationally but here at harry
reid international we have seen just
over 170 delays with just over 15
canceled flights however airlines across
the country are struggling with pilot
and staffing shortages and here in las
vegas travelers say they understand but
say that they're just happy to be here
they were they were both full carry-ons
had to be checked just because of so
many people on the plane there was no
delays i mean it was pretty good
pretty good experience
it was a risk that we were willing to
take i suppose but i just put myself in
a headspace to go with the flow and if
we're delayed that's okay and if we're
on time that's awesome delta airlines is
handing out travel waivers to some
passengers impacted by operational
delays that airline is also said to be
moving employees around to compensate
for staffing shortages currently as you
can see most flights here have arrived
on time with airline spirit and
southwest seeming to have the most
delays thus far reporting in harry reid
international airport madison kimbrough
live local now